before i ask about the film if someone
has actually never seen any of your work
before what is the first thing you want
them watching and why
oh god you're gonna um out of all my
movies
you know what out of all the probably
kingsman because that was where
everything i'd learned i put it all into
one film so
the first kingsman
i felt like maybe i am directing
uh you thanked peter jackson in the
credits and i'm just curious what was
the thank you for
um
ironically i i i went to i went and
watched his documentary um and
we were beginning to get this film off
the ground that's how long ago it was
it's documentary world war one
and
i was nervous because there's other
elements in the film
that people might be going oh whoa whoa
one wasn't like that i think they think
it's all black and white and gruesome
and i was and and jackson
highlighted that you know there was you
had good weather during world war one
you had people making jokes
deep you know gallows humor and
soldier's humor so i we didn't know each
other but i reached out to him and and
then he invited me around for to his
house for a drink when he was in england
and he had all this world war i had no
idea he was a wall he had all this world
war one memorabilia he gave me some
things books
and he brought it to life and he really
gave me the confidence he said he said
thank god you're making a movie about
world war one that people might actually
want to watch right remember this before
1917 where it was called as well um and
and then he went to help so weta helped
with some of the cg as well and it's
really hard to get wetter because you
know
they're the best and of and um
and so yeah i wanted to thank him he was
he was he made me believe in what making
a world war one film he taught me a lot
about world war one and uh helped me
with the cg so yeah he's uh he's a you
know he seems he's a very nice man
i i've spoken to him a few times he's a
very nice man may i ask what sequences
wedda contributed it on was it like a
certain shot or stuff that you were
you know
the world war one section
yeah
he was very interested and he said okay
we'll help you with that
right that makes a lot of sense and i
yeah um uh can you talk a little bit
about working with ben davis on the
aesthetic of the film and trying to and
what you wanted to do with this compared
to the other two kingsman movies well
ben didn't do the other two so ben
yeah
he was my partner in crime back in layer
cake days we did layer cake stardust and
kick ass
and
he
i
ben is the king of long lens photography
right his dad was one of the best long
lens dps
he used to shoot all the football on
film for the world cups long lens so
when you you know when you're doing long
lens on someone playing a game of
football and keeping it in focus and
operating so he and i said to him i want
to go back to the old technique long
lens photography he even got the lenses
rebuilt that lawrence for arabia was
shot on
and we just we went old school and he
wasn't scared of that i see i said do
you mind us being brave and really
composing our shots
and really going back to that epic style
of filmmaking that which was you know we
all we watched lawrence of arabia and
the man who'd be king together and i
said this has to be the man who'll be
kingsman and let's bring back
that style of filmmaking um and
he did it he did it you know and he lit
it in camera you know it sounds crazy a
lot of these movies no one bothers
lighting anymore it's just data
capturing where as long as it's got the
right level of light they can manipulate
and change everything in the grade and
we're like no let's help it in the grade
but let's not create the look in the
grade
uh as you may know about me i love
asking about the editing process because
that's ultimately where it comes
together um did you have when you when
you put this together did you have a
much longer cut or was the finished film
very close to what you you know shot
no it's very different we cut about an
hour out
and we
yeah it was the hardest thing about the
cut
was the balance of
you know some people watching him give
me the criticism which is going to come
i'm used to it by now i'll tell you um
of what is this an action adventure
movie or a period drama and how do these
things come together and what are you
doing and why is this not more like
kingsman or is it why is it well all
that stuff just it's the answer is
that's what we're doing in the edit
trying to blend
real life history
not real history
emotion
pathos
fun and action and bring it all together
um so it was uh
the hardest edit i've ever done it took
a lot it did take a long time
what is it one of these things where
fans like me will ever see some of that
footage or is it all in the vault
i have a hell of a vault now a footage
you might think i i don't
i don't like
deleted scenes being shown out of
context you know when you on these dvds
they just whack them up and so i drive
everyone nuts because they're all you
know they're already trying to get them
whenever the dvd of this comes out and
i'd rather maybe in
x amount of years sit down
and do a proper cut with everything in
like by the way
i just watched rocky versus drago last
night just because like
you know i i couldn't believe it i
thought there's a new cut and stuff yeah
i was watching it there's a few moments
you could see which was the new stuff
other stuff i you know haven't seen it
so long that i wasn't sure but but
i think that's the way
to do it if you're going to show scenes
put them that they're not good enough to
be in the cut then they're not good
enough to show
so and
stuff that would work if we did a longer
car you know there's a lot there's quite
a few of my films now we could kick ass
we could do a longer cut um
uh kingsman both kingsman it's
definitely the second one this one uh
stardust not as much
layer cake
there's no layer cake we
you know i mean
everything went in there otherwise we've
been too short so uh yeah so if i'm not
when i spoke to you for the second
kingsman movie i believe you told me you
had like an hour of footage
that didn't make the cut and you were
thinking about using some of it for
kingsman three
as like flashbacks or ways of
making the story better is that still
the case
yes kingsman three is ready to go
um
yeah it's the keys with
i mean touch wood you know
but yes that's we want to be shooting
out september at the latest next year
are you still planning on using any of
that footage from kingsman 2
of that yes yes right so that that
i want to drill down on that but i i
will leave you alone so
i want to ask about one specific
sequence in the film because i
absolutely love the rasputin big fight
sequence and the way that you
married karate kung fu
russian dance everything about that
sequence is so unique and also
representative of the way you craft
action which is unlike other people can
you sort of talk about putting that
sequence together and what you wanted to
accomplish with it
yeah first of all rest in peace to my
partner in crime sadly died which is
brad allen and
you know brad is uh is i mean argyle
will be the last example of our work
together because we we before he died
we'd already planned out the action and
um
uh
yeah he's the only person i can go to
saying look i've got an idea i want to
do a rasputin fight where we use cossack
dancing ballet dancing the tchaikovsky
medley
and he looks and he goes yep that sounds
great everybody else will go what are
you talking literally everybody else
what are you talking about and then we
sit in a room and we bring in the
dancers bring in the ac the action
bringing these stunt guys bringing the
actors and we just forge it and forge it
and forge it so that when we shoot it
it's ready to go i mean it's it's um
and uh it was
yeah it was it was um
that's there's a there's a rescue in
action sequence which
in an extended cut will put back in
um but um
uh yeah it's it's i think the difference
is i always try to tell a story in the
action all the time you know it's like
every beat story
story
story and how do we make it original and
fun but story story story so
um and how is it not going to be boring
and repetitive of what we've done before
and brad
bought into that with me there are other
second unit directors it really is just
bang bang bang explosion explosion bang
bang bang the end
we try not to do it that way
yeah and again that's one of the reasons
i really enjoy your action stuff i
already got to stop i'm just going to
say congratulations on the movie always
awesome to talk with you um i hope the
film's a huge hit well if you've got any
other questions or you want to just get
in touch
100
you know um thank you so much sir
all right nice to see you again